FM E
, THE , ARORPL IOF ONG SHELLING'
LARGEST EA
>> MELISSA B
E DIRECTOR OTHADMITTED THIIS TSD
DOUT WHAT THEEN
NG THE OVER THE COMING DAYS
FRAUGHT THAN THEY HAJIM,T WA MOR
SHELLING THIS RUSSIAN-HELD TOWN
EN SINCE THECCATGAN INAR ALLS TE
ED             REACRSTURNED  OFZ
NUCLEAR PLAN
THE CONTEXT IN W TTHIS MORNING.
WOULD Y ON A THEREIT TOOK THEM C
SHOULD HAVE AS JIMENTIONED,
THREE HO
ERGY
MAKING A CLAIMKRAINI
ONCE THEY CROSS THE FRONT LINE
WHERE THE POWER PLANT UKRAIN
E R THEISA
RISKS THEY
IS, OF COURASU SAY,EY W
THE RYWSITWHAT THEY'LL
HAVE.EA
VR SUSSI THEY HAD
E VERY FACT THYTHING THEY TO SE.
DESPITE TH
ISD . PLAN IS A  THIS MORNING, T
IS THAT RAFASSY, HIMSELF,  HEADH
Y AT
SAHIT W  YOU L E TH
SCAL D.A BELL IN THK G USS GENEY
CLARK.
GENERAL CLARK, ALWAYS GOOD T
FIRST,
TO THELANTIARS AT LEAST  BN WE
>> I THE
DANGER TO THE G LIKE
THE RUSSIANS HAVE MANIPULATED
THE SITUTHIN MIEL
AS A FORTRESS.
U N PUT YOUR FORCES IN IT
ABLEFOT  AASSO I ONL
BUT ALSO GOOD
MANUFACTUR B IT IS A SMART TSS
I DOTO ASK YOUEC K WE HAVENHEIRT
STS IN SIGNICA U
FOCUSED ON KHERSON.AINIANES
THEY NEED TO TAKE ANLD
N VE THE CAPABILIT
IF TE ITO MOVEEPAT LF
EDED IN CUTTING OFF
SSINFORCE S AND RELYACROSS TPROP
CONTROR BIG .
D AVIT IS
LTTACK.BUT THEY N
HI ARTILLERY, AI
FIGHTER BOMBERANNG R
THIS IS A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
TA ATILL
E N LEARNI
N REPORTING THAT UKRAINE AND
TH WAR T
DEGREE I THIS.
COSEAWAY FROA
TH RES O
KHN.
WELL, ABSI MEAN, LOOK, IT IS LD
FRANCE A D-DAYF  COULD BE INANB
SO OF THIS50TERS O
FOES IR TOCESSFUL.RE A LOT OF DU
HAO CONC
D THAT'S WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE
>> LET'SATAN ORE WE GO.
FORCES TO THMI TO BACK
FTER T EM
HE HASOTTHGH FOR AL MOBILIZATI R
CAATM MEO MINIMIZE DISRUPTION ON
E RUSSIAPUTI STRATEGIC -- IT I
STRATEGIC DECISION BY PUTITHAT'
WGIPOWATCH.
GENERAL WESLEY C, AL GOOD T
>> THANK
>>> THIS JUSCNN, THE
CHAI ORUSSIAIL PRODUCER,AS
DIED AFTAL OF
SINDT A
E
EP
CONFMEMAV'DEATH,MEE CAUSE BEIN
THE FATAL INSTEA
IN MARCH, SHORTLTEUKRAINE,
CALLOR THENE
N OF THENOTE CNN H
FOUND AT LEAE PROMINENT
RTY SUICIDE SINCE LATENUARY.